Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Arrow Huntress came back and gave us a
nice teaser for future Birds of Prey episodes
in season 3 and beyond.
There was a lot of secret identity revealing
teased and Slade also made a huge move against
Oliver.
So let’s start with a big question.
How far gone is too far gone.
Let’s look at what happened to Helena in
this episode and apply that logic to Slade.
First though, next week is a very Deathstroke
centric episode.
So if you have questions about that or about
Birds of Prey, leave them in the comments
and I’ll include them in my Q&A video tomorrow.
Be sure to subscribe to get that.
The writers really did a lot to mirror the
Huntress and Deathstroke characters, so because
there was so much awesome to talk about.
Let’s do Top 5 moments and try to answer
the question, is Slade too far gone to come
back.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Here we go, Number 5 - Secret Identities being
revealed.
Felicity’s quote heavily foreshadows the
next couple of episodes.
It’s getting really hard to tell who know’s
whose secret identity.
Marc Guggenheim revealed that more people
are going to learn Oliver’s secret identity.
Based on the situation Thea got herself into
in the last couple minutes of the episode
and the cell phone moment Detective Lance
had with Oliver.
I think it’s safe to say they’re both
going to learn who’s been shooting all those
baby Arrows around.
Detective Lance in particular has been getting
more and more complicit with the Arrow since
Sara started working with him.
It’s like he’s an unspoken member of the
team.
Gordon never learned Batman’s identity,
or at least never let it show that he knew.
So I hope Lance does the same thing with Oliver.
I want him to figure it out, but I like the
idea of Oliver not knowing that he knows.
Thea on the other hand is probably not going
to take it very well.
Everyone has been lying and keeping secrets
from her.
It just feels like they’re clearing the
path for Merlin to swoop in.
The John Barrowman cameo meter is off the
scale right now.
I also really though the Canary would reveal
herself to Laurel.
Which I also think is coming.
Remember the title of Episode 19 is The Man
Under The Hood.
But that doesn’t mean that they Canary couldn’t
out herself to Laurel.
Who else gets the vibe that pretty soon it’s
going to be open war against anyone in a mask.
Bad or good..
Number 4 - For the Record Don’t Call Me
Speedy.
Marc Guggenheim keeps using the Arsenal name
when talking about Roy, but technically they’re
not really settling on anything yet.
Oliver called Roy Speedy not because he wanted
to give him that nickname.
But just to remind him of Thea to shock him
out of his mirakuru induced rage coma.
It’s possible that if Thea is the one to
die this season, Roy could take up the name
Speedy to honor her.
The list of candidates for people who Slade
will kill is really being localized to Oliver’s
family.
Thea, being the biggest teaser going into
next week.
It seemed like Roy agreed with Oliver’s
request to keep her at a distance.
So I don’t expect Slade to turn Roy against
Oliver, but I do think the writers will tease
that in episode 20.
Seeing Red.
They keep focusing on how pissed off Roy gets.
Like that last scene with him smashing the
bracelet.
I have a feeling Roy is going to ‘let the
darkness in’.
Number 3 - Laurel Let’s the Darkness In
Her last scene just felt so sinister.
But I think they just want us to think that
Laurel isn’t going use baby Arrows to go
after what she wants.
Teeing up her confrontation with Brother Blood.
It really feels like with Oliver going after
Slade, she’ll be responsible for dealing
with the underling.
Earlier this year, everyone was wondering
if they would kill Sara off and use that as
the catalyst for Laurel to become the true
Black Canary.
As much as she’s course corrected her life,
I don’t feel like that’s going to happen.
It just feels like they’re investing so
much in Caity Lotz’ Canary that it would
be a complete waste of an amazing character
to kill her off right after teasing a Birds
of Prey team-up in a future season.
If you’re not sure about that, the final
scene is almost a dead giveaway that Huntress
will be given the Suicide Squad speech at
some point.
Hopefully she’ll be back before the finale.
Number 2 - The Canary VS The Huntress
There were two awesome fight scenes with some
nice Oliver jokes.
Just that Oliver definitely has a type.
And that type is stabby girls in black leather.
I loved their fight scenes, both of them.
Especially Canary getting pushed out the window.
I thought it was nice that Sara’s only reaction
to learning about Oliver’s relationship
with her was with subtle bemusement.
That’s one of the things that I think Arrow
is doing well.
Not defining it’s female characters in terms
of their sexual relationships the male characters.
Also I thank them for downplaying the love
triangles, I’m sure tumblr has some really
funny Slade Oliver ‘ships though.
I generally try to avoid those types of posts.
So I don’t have to burn my eyes out.
and my Number 1 moment - Slade takes Thea
and sets the stage for the beginning of the
end.
Remember my big question, how far gone is
too far gone for Slade.
Oliver tried to kill him on the island.
But taking Thea with the assumption that he’ll
threaten to kill her kind of makes it seem
like that’s what’s going to be the point
of no return for him.
They haven’t mentioned Jericho or Ravager
in several episodes, but I’m still holding
out hope that Oliver will use them to try
and bring Slade back mentally.
The next episode, Deathstroke, is actually
a deep dive into Slade’s head.
It’s really like a complete Slade story
for an hour.
Connecting more dots from the island to now.
We’ll also get more of an explanation of
what the mirakuru has done to his brain.
Because it’s really the reason all this
is happening.
They spent the entire episode mirroring Huntress’
story with Slade’s.
And she found some redemption, or at least
came back to sanity.
I think it’s foreshadowing that Oliver will
be able to redeem Slade a little.
Not completely, because I’m hoping that
Slade continues to develop as Deathstroke
the mercenary in future seasons.
But enough to stop him from trying to destroy
Oliver.
They’ll probably be frenemies for life given
all that’s happened between them.
But now it’s your turn to answer my question.
Can Oliver redeem Slade this season?
Will the darkness quote unquote, ever get
out?
Overall the episode was a solid B plus for
use of Huntress.
I loved her character and how dark they made
her.
Last time we saw her in season 1 she was pissed
off and stabby, this time she was a full on
killer.
Not so much that she couldn’t find some
redemption.
But it seemed like her Helena persona returned
by the end.
I’m so hoping Amanda Waller pays her a visit
soon.
How else will they be able to do a Birds of
Prey episode next season?
Felicity had one of the best lines of the
episode even though it feels like she was
barely part of the story.
Superheroes will be unmasked shortly.
Ultimately resulting in the growth of Team
Arrow.
It’s getting really crowded in that basement.
Remember though, there’s still the threat
of a major character dying.
Currently Thea is at the top of the list.
Let me know who you think is going to die
this season?
Thea, Sara or Moira?
Remember, Q&A tomorrow.
So leave your questions you want me to include.
Right now click here for last week’s episode
and click here for that Q&A link.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!